do you think the war on drugs
has done more positive or negative for
the world
depends on which world you live in the
war on drugs has been hugely beneficial
to law enforcement uh to the media uh to
people who make [ __ ] tv shows um
the sopranos the wire all of those shows
they benefit from this kind of nonsense
um
um
who else have benefited people who
provide treatment many of them benefit
from the war on drugs the folks who do
urine testing for drugs they've all
benefited they're making mad money uh
people who run prisons uh the phone
companies who charge the prisoners uh
the people who run the hotels that are
around the prisons where people's family
have to come and stay the restaurants
they they are making out like bandits
but many of us are getting screwed as a
society uh we
in general we're getting screwed but
there are people who are just benefiting
handsomely that's why it continues
politicians benefit i mean whether
you're democrat or republican you have
the same stance on drugs anyway so you
they all benefit from this
so many questions i want to ask you
because you're challenging a lot of
beliefs that people have about drugs
about society in general so it's
difficult for me to ask the right
questions here but
if you could if you were uh
with a
sort of uh snap of a finger change the
world
what from a policy perspective
would you and from just a i don't know a
human to human perspective what would
you like to see in the united states of
america
in terms of that fixes some of the
problems we're discussing here first of
all i would not we wouldn't be arresting
anybody for drugs anymore that would go
away
um the folks who are in prison for drugs
that would go away their records would
be a sponge that would just go away
and then we work on a system
to make sure that
responsible adults can
legally attain obtain these substances
and we will have a corresponding
educational system to teach people how
to do this
that's where i would start initially
yeah the the arresting for drug use
or anything drug-related is absurd
especially in the context of how
destructive alcohol is and tobacco
alcohol can be destructive to some
people but alcohol also is a
hugely beneficial drug to be honest
which i couldn't have gotten through
many of the sort of receptions and
functions i had to go through as the
chair of the department um without
alcohol yeah you have a line i really
liked um the vast amount of predictably
favorable favorable drug effects
intrigued me so much so that i expanded
my own drug use to take advantage of the
wide array of beneficial outcomes
specific drugs can offer
the the part that entertained me was
this to put this in personal terms my
position as department chairman from
2016 to 2019 was far more detrimental to
my health than my drug use ever was i
mean there there is there is a standard
we're treating drugs certain kinds of
drugs that's completely different than
the standard we're treating everything
else in our lives
yeah i mean it's it's almost difficult
to snap out of it as i'm listening to
you and and reading your work
um
it's it's uh
it's difficult because it's like
why is everybody living this
idea that certain drugs
are so horribly destructive and others
are not
and we just kind of fix that idea and
then there's this narrative
um
i'd hate to be so cynical to think that
there is just like a system that just
propagates narratives
i i always kind of think that uh truth
wins out
truth is the best narrative i believe
that too obviously that's why i'm out
here and putting subjecting myself to
this sort of criticism and so forth but
because i believe that truth
ultimately wins out but i might be wrong
but i have to live my life
like
it's true otherwise then i have no hope
then why be here well kind of if you can
steal man or at least show respect to a
criticism you've i'm sure received
uh quite a bit of criticism for your
work i i've heard quite a bit of bs
criticism sort of ignorance
stuff that don't actually pay attention
to your work
uh but is there some serious like is
there some pushback that makes you think
uh twice
people say like i'm presenting a too
rosy picture of drugs you know like i
don't want to do that i don't want
people to think that i'm not aware of
the potential negative effects of any
activity including drug use um and so
i do acknowledge that uh there are
potential harms associated with drugs i
acknowledge that in the book
but the fact remains the beneficial
effects far outweigh the potential
harmful effects and we have technology
information to help people to minimize
the likelihood of those negative effects
but
this sort of
approach that we have where we
say we're only exclusively presenting
the harmful effects and that should make
people keep people safe i i just have a
problem with that but i i certainly i uh
i take the point that
um people say there are negative effects
absolutely i absolutely agree
you